Hey, this is Presh Talwakar.
Martin is a gardener in Mathland.
There are 100 poisonous flowers
in his garden
that he wants to destroy.
On their own,
the flowers do not change in number.
Martin has a spray to kill
the poisonous flowers,
but the spray works
only in a specific way.
The spray has settings to destroy
exactly 3,
5, 14, or 17 flowers instantly.
The spray only works if
there are at least as many flowers
as the setting.
If there are two flowers, for example,
the setting for 3 does nothing.
Furthermore, if at least
one flower survives
after he sprays them,
the flowers instantly grow back
based on how many died.
If 3 die, then 12 grow back.
If 5 die, then 17 grow back.
If 14 die, then 8 grow back.
If 17 die, 2 grow back.
If the number of flowers
is ever exactly zero,
then the flowers never grow back.
Can Martin ever get rid of the
poisonous flowers in his garden?
You can assume
he has an unlimited amount of spray.
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try,
and when you're ready,
keep watching the video for the solution.
So, from the initial
100 flowers,
you can try experimenting
the different combinations
of the flowers
you can spray,
and keep track of
how many flowers remain.
But no matter how you try,
you're not gonna be able to
get rid of all the flowers.
We can understand why
by thinking forward
and reasoning backwards.
So in order for
Martin to succeed,
there needs to be
3, 5, 14, or 17 flowers
just before the last time
he sprays the flowers.
This means
from the initial 100 flowers,
Martin has to decrease
the number of flowers
by exactly 97, 95, 86,
or 83 flowers.
Let's consider the net change
after each setting of the spray.
If he uses a setting of 3,
he kills 3,
but 12 grow back,
which leads to plus 9 flowers.
For the setting of 5,
there is a net change
of plus 12 flowers.
For 14 setting,
he decreases the number
of flowers by 6,
and for the 17 setting,
he decreases the number
of flowers by 15.
On each setting of the spray,
Martin can only change the
number of flowers
by +9, +12, -6, or -15,
and there's a pattern
to these numbers.
They are all multiples of 3.
Since Martin only changes
the number of flowers
by a multiple of 3,
has to change by 3x
for certain integer
values of x.
Now, since the numbers 97, 95,
86, and 83 are not multiples of 3,
that means Martin
is not capable
of decreasing the initial number
by exactly any
of those numbers.
Therefore, we can conclude
Martin can never get rid of
all of the poisonous flowers.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video.
Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math and
game theory.
You can catch me on my blog,
"Mind Your Decisions,"
which you can follow on
Facebook, Google+, and Patreon.
You can catch me on social media:
@preshtalwalkar,
and if you like this video,
please check out my books.
There are links
in the video description.